let's go to Willie from Oregon Willie
welcome to the show what's on your mind
today
hey I was just curious if you have paid
any attention to the truth social ads
that it did popping up no we just did a
story earlier this week about how the a
company that was going to invest 140
million to merge with truth social
they're just completely bailing and
Truth social is likely going to fail
soon but what where are they running ads
uh well there was an update to the app
and so I did that and all sudden notice
that these ads started popping up like
it looks like Trump's the only one
paying for ads just anti-bitum okay uh
there's one for you know 2500 free
knives and reading through that was like
arm yourselves oh my goodness
it's pretty dark are you on when you're
on the app do you just look to see the
wacky stuff that gets posted are you on
there to kind of like argue with people
or to troll like what's your what do you
do on the app
oh uh could we cuss on this or no no
please don't okay
uh just messing with Trump and following
the the cuckoo there I see have you had
anybody like directly attack you because
of the things you post
oh yeah I did that for a little bit
um you know I there's not much Common
Sense on there so it's kind of pointless
to uh do anything but just like to keep
an eye on what that guy's uh
up to and talking and like you know last
night it looked like he he just reposts
the craziest stuff and uh it's pretty
scary yeah I like to keep an eye on him
see what he's up to but the that you
should look uh at some of the ads that
have been popping up on there they're
very strange I'll check that out I'll
check that out thanks for bringing in to
my attention
yeah yeah I think it's worth uh looking
into and talking about a little bit all
right Willie from Oregon very much
appreciate it thank you very very much
uh really really important stuff
happening on truth and it soon should
fail completely all right okay let's
take a very quick break if you're
holding to talk to me keep holding
because we're going right back to the
phones in a moment